we start today not with a profile in
Courage but with a profile in cowardice
and the guy's name is Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis has come up with the most
squirrely I mean we're talking nuttier
than squirrel poop excuse the metaphor
uh the squirreliest way to avoid
answering a very simple question did
failed twice indicted twice impeached
former president Donald Trump violate
the peaceful transfer of power which was
almost I guess we could say they tried
to stop on January 6 2021
and Ron DeSantis comes up with an answer
that is it's so stupid it's almost
laughable and something very strange is
going on with my hair as you can see and
I I really do apologize to the audience
for that continued issues
um he says I wasn't in Washington DC on
January 6th so I I don't really know
what happened oh did
we'll get back to that we'll take a
listen to this
do you believe that Trump violated the
peaceful transfer of power a key
principle that of American democracy
that we must uphold are you in high
school
yeah where do you go to school you go
around here
uh Vermont I live in New Hampshire oh
okay so you've been from Vermont well
thank you for the question so here's
what I know
if this election is about Biden's
failures and our vision for the future
we are going to win if it's about
relitigating things that happen two
three years ago we're gonna lose and so
by the way all Ron DeSantis is doing is
relitigating covid and talking about how
he was so much better than Trump on
covet so even so he's already lying but
then we're getting to the real Whopper I
can tell you this
tell us one
good morning
I can tell you this
I can point you to
Tallahassee Florida on I believe January
5th 2023 uh we had a transition of power
from my first Administration to my
second because I noticed that this is
completely unrelated to the question one
re-election in a historic fashion and at
the end of the day you know we need to
win and we need to get this done so uh I
wasn't anywhere near Washington that day
I have nothing to do with what happened
that day obviously I didn't enjoy seeing
you know what would happen but we've got
to go forward on that remember the
question wasn't were you in DC or did
you have anything to do with it the
question was will you actually denounce
what Donald Trump did it's a cowardly
cop-out to say I didn't enjoy seeing
what happened Well Ron didn't enjoy it
and I didn't enjoy it but I'm willing to
say Trump was at least partially
responsible for what took place by
inciting his followers Ron DeSantis
isn't willing to say that this this is
the I hate to use the term the Trump
term this is a low energy
cowardly way to run a campaign if you're
actually going to make the case that
you're the better choice than Trump
on all fronts you're going to say I
never would have said the things Trump
said because any sensible person would
realize how some of his followers would
take it and I wouldn't want that
responsibility on my shoulders I will
govern in a different way I would never
do such a thing and by the way I'm also
better on policy but instead DeSantis
knows he sees the numbers this is all a
numbers game in order to have a shot
at winning the primary DeSantis knows he
either needs to dramatically increase
Republican primary turnout which it just
doesn't seem like it's going to happen
or he needs to take some of Trump's
current support because Trump's already
polling 52 percent and DeSantis is
calculating I can't take Trump's support
from his hardcore supporters by saying
he was responsible for the riots I can't
do it they're they're it's not going to
work so instead DeSantis is taking the
Cowardly way out saying he didn't like
what happened and uh that people should
vote for him and if Trump gets indicted
a third or fourth time and it becomes so
chaotic that he can't even run DeSantis
will just be there
for some Maga people to support him I
don't think it's going to work I don't
think it's going to work at all by the
way here's one other clip from this
event while at the same campaign event
in New Hampshire
DeSantis says what Trump did wrong
wasn't to say lock up Hillary it was to
stop saying I remember these rallies in
2016. it was exciting yeah drain the
swamp I also remember lock her up lock
her up right and then two weeks after
the election oh don't forget about it
forget I ever said that no no no one
thing you'll get from me if I tell you
I'm going to do something I'm not just
saying that for an election right and
there are promises I could make that may
help me marginally politically that I
don't know that I could that I could
necessarily follow through on so I will
not make that Ron DeSantis is saying the
problem with Trump wasn't that he said
lock up Hillary remember
no evidence of crimes no indictment no
conviction but they oh we're for Law and
Order but you have no reason to lock up
Hillary de Santa says the problem wasn't
that Trump said Locker up the problem
was that he stopped saying it and that
he didn't do it this guy is as dangerous
as Trump he's exposing it every single
day